[Aplausos]
[Música]
los nuevos países han surgido en el
tablero político mundial o al menos en
el mapamundi ruso el pasado lunes 21 de
febrero el presidente de la federación
rusa vladimir putin firmó los decretos
que reconocen la independencia de la
república popular de don ex y la
república popular de lugansk en el este
de ucrania y eso no es todo el
presidente ruso también le ordenó a su
ministro de defensa el despliegue
inmediato del ejército ruso en estas dos
nuevas repúblicas para llevar a cabo una
operación de mantenimiento de la paz lo
que por supuesto en palabras de putin
significa demostrar que controlas el
territorio
de hecho en esta misma línea el propio
gobierno ruso ha enviado a la duma para
su ratificación los tratados de defensa
y seguridad alcanzados con las nuevas
repúblicas populares dos tratados que
por supuesto como no podía ser de otra
manera le encargan a moscú la protección
de estos territorios le facultan para
desplegar tropas y le permiten construir
bases militares en ellos vamos que
estamos ante una de esas grandes obras
de teatro que tanto gusta de moscú aquí
en visual político ya os contamos cómo
esta jugada el reconocimiento pleno de
la independencia de estas dos repúblicas
era algo más que probable por así
decirlo es una jugada que forma parte
del manual habitual de moscú es algo que
ya hemos visto en los casos de
transnistria asia y osetia del sur con
todo el despliegue de tropas rusas en
las autoproclamadas repúblicas populares
de don ex y lugansk supone la primera
incursión formal de tropas rusas en
territorio legalmente ucraniano y una
violación flagrante de los acuerdos de
mick 2 algo que ha disparado la tensión
y el miedo a que esta operación sea sólo
el preludio de una invasión a gran
escala
[Música]
lo que por cierto sigue siendo negado
por el propio presidente de ucrania
volodymyr celesc y bajo su punto de
vista de este movimiento a pesar de
suponer sí una clara violación de la
soberanía del país y de los acuerdos de
mis dos simplemente ha legalizado la
actividad que el ejército ruso lleva
realizando la región desde el año 2014
por así decirlo la realidad que todo el
mundo conocía que moscú negaba y que
ahora nos alarma que se haya confirmado
sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta como
rusia rodeado ucrania por tierra mar y
aire
[Música]
sea como sea el caso amigos es que toda
esta situación pone sobre la mesa a unas
cuantas preguntas qué consecuencias
puede tener este reconocimiento que
supone para el conflicto entre rusia
ucrania y occidente y la pregunta que la
hora de la verdad puede que a muchos más
os peque la curiosidad como son
exactamente estas repúblicas pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
las nuevas repúblicas populares
desde su autoproclamada independencia en
el año 2014 las nuevas repúblicas han
quedado aisladas casi por completo del
resto de ucrania del resto del cráneo y
prácticamente de todo el mundo con la
excepción claro está de rusia hoy forman
uno de los territorios más opacos
cerrados y militarizados de todo el
planeta la república popular de don -ex
tiene unos 8.900 kilómetros cuadrados y
unos 23 millones de habitantes y este
hombre que veis en pantalla denis pussy
link que formó parte de una enorme
estafa piramidal en rusia y ucrania es
su líder por su parte la república
popular del uars que tiene unos 8.300
kilómetros cuadrados y 16 millones de
habitantes en total hablamos de unos 17
mil 300 kilómetros cuadrados el
equivalente a la superficie de kuwait o
social área y 39 millones de habitantes
aunque la población podría ser en
realidad muy inferior digamos que
resulta difícil de precisar por los
enormes desplazamientos de población que
ha provocado el conflicto que comenzó en
el año 2014 el año que dio forma a estas
dos nuevas repúblicas
[Música]
amigos el día 22 de febrero del 2014 el
por aquel entonces presidente de ucrania
y aliado de moscú viktor yanúkovich huyó
de la capital y dejó su puesto como
consecuencia de las protestas desatadas
por la revolución de la humanidad y ahí
justo ahí es cuando comenzó la tormenta
rusia respondió a la revolución del euro
mayrán anexionándose crimea con los
famosos hombres de verde y alimentando
la sublevación del este del país sin
embargo si la toma de crimea fue limpia
los levantamientos en el este de ucrania
fueron un caos las protestas en dones y
lugar pronto dieron paso a un conflicto
armado entre el nuevo gobierno de
ucrania y las milicias locales
respaldadas por moscú inicialmente los
rebeldes pro rusos avanzaron rápido aquí
se hicieron con el control de la
práctica totalidad de los hablar de
tones y lugansk sin embargo el
contraataque del ejército ucraniano y
particularmente de los batallones de
voluntarios obligaron a rusia a enviar
tanques baterías antiaéreas y artillería
de largo alcance para frenar la ofensiva
y obligar a ucrania a pactar un alto el
fuego y firmar los acuerdos de mins 2
desde entonces la línea del frente se ha
mantenido más o menos estable
los acuerdos de mixtos fueron un intento
de poner fin al conflicto impulsados por
francia y alemania- con el escepticismo
de eeuu y el acuerdo reconocía la
soberanía ucraniana a cambio de que
quien le otorgara a las regiones
sublevadas un estatus de autonomía
especial claro que las definiciones
fueron imprecisas y al final ninguna de
las partes cumplió su palabra en
cualquier caso si hoy por allá algo está
claro es que por mucho que moleste en
bruselas una vez que rusia ha reconocido
la plena independencia de estos
territorios estos acuerdos ya no valen
nada son un papel mojado
además el conflicto nunca se terminó el
fuego de los francotiradores y los
intercambios de artillería fueron
constantes por ambos bandos y en total
se calcula que esta guerra ha causado
entre 14.000 y 20.000 víctimas mortales
además de por lo menos 2 millones de
desplazados que en otras palabras que
los acuerdos demmings 2 fueron otra de
esas grandilocuentes operaciones
europeas repletas de buenas intenciones
pero que a la hora de la verdad nadie se
las cree ni siquiera a los propios
firmantes y el caso es que así es como
surgieron las nuevas repúblicas
populares de don ex y lugansk dos
repúblicas que viven prácticamente bajo
un estado de guerra permanente las
instituciones amigos fueron asaltadas se
impuso un modelo ultra nacionalista
conservador y militarizado y muchas por
no decir la mayoría de las grandes
empresas y de los activos productivos
como las minas o las fábricas de acero
fueron expropiadas o puestas a
disposición de oligarcas amigos de moscú
este es por ejemplo el caso de jeffrén y
yurchenko un inversor ruso que ahora
controla los activos más valiosos y si
también se ha establecido un modelo
político policial de mano pura han
logrado reconstruir un sistema soviético
en los territorios ocupados y no el
sistema soviético de las décadas de 1960
y 1970
sino el sistema soviético de las décadas
1930 y 1940 con mazmorras con cámaras de
tortura un sistema donde las vidas se
arruinan si te atreves a escribir o
decir algo negativo sobre estas
repúblicas y sus autoridades stanislaw a
ser novelista y periodista de dónetsk y
ojo porque hablamos del que era uno de
los territorios más desarrollados de
toda ucrania por supuesto tal y como os
podéis imaginar todo esto ha tenido
consecuencias atentos
[Música]
la ruina
hoy parece difícil de creer pero hace
apenas una década don xxv una de las
sedes más importantes de la eurocopa del
año 2012 una eurocopa que fue organizada
por ucrania y polonia para albergar esta
competición la ciudad se vistió de gala
se restauró buena parte de la ciudad se
construyó un nuevo aeropuerto se
arreglaron las carreteras y se abrieron
nuevos y relucientes hoteles tampoco
resultaba extraño las regiones de don
exit lugansk formaban el conocido como
cinturón del óxido y el motor económico
de toda ucrania un importante enclave
minero industrial el hogar de las
mayores acerías de todo el país y no
sólo eso don ex también en el hogar y la
principal sede del emporio de rinat
akhmetov el hombre más rico de todo gran
ya un multimillonario cuya fortuna
forbes calcula en unos 7 mil millones de
dólares pero sea como sea el caso es que
hoy todo eso ha quedado atrás
las infraestructuras están dañadas el
servicio de telefonía móvil e internet
es irregular en el mejor de los casos la
actividad económica se ha desplomado los
empleos han desaparecido y cerca de la
mitad ojo la mitad de la población
podría haber emigrado al resto de
ucrania a rusia y al resto de europa
sobre todo a polonia y por supuesto las
empresas y las cadenas internacionales
han cerrado sus puertas a calicanto
solía haber mucho entusiasmo por la
república popular de donde al principio
todos coreaban de perez de perez de
perez ahora solo hay mucha decepción la
economía allí se ha desmoronado los
puestos de trabajo se han ido no hay
nada bueno allí oleksandr gay de voy
exiliado de la región de dones hoy estas
dos repúblicas se han convertido en
territorios muy pero que muy pobres dos
territorios que viven esencialmente del
contrabando y de la financiación rusa y
es que de hecho en ellas todo es rusia
la moneda de curso oficial es el rublo a
sus ciudadanos se les expide pasaportes
rusos y en acceso a los beneficios
sociales de rusia y sus mandatarios se
han unido al propio partido político de
putin vamos que lo de la independencia
es un poco de broma hablamos mejor y si
eso de autonomía y como mucho
el futuro además no parece nada
halagüeño sin reconocimiento
internacional las inversiones y el
comercio lo tienen muy complicado para
colmo las el reconocimiento de su
independencia por parte de rusia el
presidente joe biden ha firmado una
orden ejecutiva que prohíbe que
cualquier empresa entidad o ciudadano de
los estados unidos participe directa o
indirectamente en proyectos de inversión
exportaciones importaciones financiación
o cualquier otro negocio con estos
territorios donde esquilu guns han
quedado aislados de la comunidad
internacional lo que hasta hace poco fue
el lugar más próspero de ucrania hoy es
una enorme ruina
curiosamente han sido las ciudades
ucranianas del donbass las que han
salido más favorecidas hablamos de
ciudades que los últimos años han
recibido montones de trabajadores y
empresarios de las zonas controladas por
rusia
[Música]
y este es por ejemplo el caso de járkov
la segunda ciudad más poblada de ucrania
una ciudad que históricamente ha estado
muy ligada a rusia y que fue uno de los
principales centros de producción
militar de la unión soviética una ciudad
que los rebeldes pro rusos llegaron a
ocupar brevemente en el 2014 hasta que
fueron expulsados por una fuerza de
acción rápida del ejército ucraniano
hablamos de una ciudad donde se calcula
que en 2014 apenas un tercio de la
población era leal al gobierno ucraniano
un porcentaje amigos que ahora se podría
haber incrementado por encima del 70 por
ciento gracias precisamente a lo
diferente que ha sido su evolución
económica respecto a la que han tenido
los territorios en manos de los rebeldes
pro rusos si el mayor enemigo para moscú
puede ser precisamente la falta de
futuro que entraña su ocupación viendo
cómo están las cosas en la propia rusia
como no van a mirar los ucranianos hacia
el oeste es que de cajón ahora bien
llegados hasta aquí que supone
exactamente el reconocimiento de rusia
porque ha generado tanta alarma
a la lista
en primer lugar porque la operación para
el mantenimiento de la paz supone la
primera incursión reconocida de tropas
rusas en territorio ucraniano pero
también porque tarde o temprano podría
actuar como una excusa perfecta para la
invasión o cuanto menos para mantener la
tensión al rojo vivo fijaos por ejemplo
en este mapa
[Música]
n el podéis ver en color más oscuro el
territorio controlado por las repúblicas
populares y en color más claro el
territorio que reclaman la cuestión es
el reconocimiento ruso afecta también a
este territorio en disputa de ser así y
podríamos estar ante la justificación de
una invasión o acciones de agresión por
parte de las milicias de las repúblicas
populares que terminarán con el apoyo de
moscú rusia respalda las reclamaciones
territoriales completas de los
separatistas de ucrania
putin ha dicho públicamente que rusia
respalda todas las reivindicaciones
territoriales de los separatistas pro
rusos eso sí también dijo que
correspondía a los separatistas negociar
con que la forma de resolver esta
disputa fronteriza eso puede significar
dos cosas por un lado la excusa perfecta
para lanzar una invasión parcial sobre
todo el donbass y quizás también las
costas del mar negro si el ejército
ucraniano muestra resistencia por otro
puede ser la fórmula escogida para
elevar aún más la tensión e intentar
lograr un tanto político en la mesa de
negociación y guardarse la baza de la
invasión para el futuro
[Música]
si esto es así la presencia de tropas
rusas no tendría por qué suponer ningún
cambio útil podría apuntarse el tanto
que tanto está buscando en casa y podría
evitar la mayoría de las sanciones
internacionales
joe biden impone una ola de sanciones a
rusia por la invasión de ucrania el
presidente de los eeuu se dirige a las
élites algunos bancos y la deuda
soberana y dice que seguirán más medidas
si putin avanzar australia canadá y
japón imponen sanciones a rusia por la
crisis de ucrania en este caso el
resultado para renunciar seguiría siendo
malo tal y como ya os contamos en un
pasado vídeo pero los daños podrían ser
un poquito más limitados
[Música]
claro que si finalmente el kremlin
decide ir más allá bueno las
experiencias de don exit lugansk no nos
permiten ser optimistas con el futuro de
los ucranianos y tampoco ojo con el de
los propios rusos con una invasión no
ganarían nada y perderían mucho además
por supuesto de una rotunda condena
internacional
tenemos información creíble que indica
que las fuerzas rusas están creando
listas de ucranianos identificados para
ser asesinados o enviados a campamentos
después de una ocupación militar es
probable que las fuerzas rusas utilicen
medidas letales para dispersar protestas
pacíficas o contrarrestar de otra manera
los ejercicios pacíficos de resistencia
percibida de las poblaciones civiles
bucks iba crocker embajador de eeuu ante
la oficina de las naciones unidas pero
llegados hasta aquí turno para ti cómo
piensas que van a discurrir los
acontecimientos será la intervención en
estas 2 autoproclamadas repúblicas
populares el preludio de acciones
mayores déjanos tu respuesta por aquí
abajo en los comentarios y si este vídeo
te resultó interesante no olvides darle
a like muy pronto os hablaremos con todo
detalle del caso de georgia así que no
olvidéis suscribiros si aún no lo habéis
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]